die kernfusion produziert eine unmenge
an energie und wird deswegen auch als
die neue primäre energiequelle
schlechthin gehandelt vielleicht schon
bald die lösung aller energieprobleme
weltweit ganz vorne im rennen mit dabei
ist auch der fusionsreaktor namen
stalker marquez t40 bereits im
vergangenen jahr hat er erstmals plasma
erzeugt und wird so als heißer kandidat
gehandelt mit dem bereits in naher
zukunft die fusions kraft auch
kommerziell genutzt werden könnte ihr
habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp
gewünscht und bekommt jetzt alle
wichtigen facts zum thema poker marquez
t40 herzlich willkommen bei kicks und
science fiction
ja und wir bei whatsapp mitmachen können
dass er vater am ende des videos
die kernfusion wäre ein
riesenfortschritt um die energie problem
mit dieser welt in angriff zu nehmen und
so tüfteln forschungsteams weltweit
daran im großen und ganzen ist die sonne
das natürliche vorbild für das was
während einer kernfusion passieren die
atomkerne von wasserstoff verschmelzen
unter sehr hohem druck und bei sehr
hohen temperaturen miteinander im
gegensatz zur kernspaltung bilden
vereinfacht gesagt zwei leichter atome
ein schweres die gesamtmasse des neuen
atoms ist geringer als die der beiden
einzeln das was fehlt das ist die
entstandene energie das tolle der ganze
prozess ist sehr viel ungefährlicher als
die atom spaltung in kernkraftwerken wie
wir sie heute kennen
denn selbst bei einem unfall setzt ein
fusionsreaktor nicht die unmengen an
radioaktiver strahlung frei wie ankam
kraftwerk und zudem haben die
radioaktiven stoffe die heber entstehen
eine halbwertszeit von jahrzehnten und
eben nicht von jahrmillionen wie bei
einem atomkraftwerk und genau diese
gründe stacheln forschungsgruppen
weltweit an fusionsreaktoren immer
leistungsfähiger zu machen damit die von
ihnen erzeugte fusions kraft
letztendlich auch kommerziell nutzbar
ist denn auch wenn die vorteile der
fusions kraft außer frage steht ist die
erzeugung und vermarktung von
fusionsenergie weiterhin eine technische
und wissenschaftliche herausforderung in
großbritannien fort beispielsweise das
private unternehmen talker mark energy
daran
auf der webseite heißt es die fusion ist
die ideale energiequelle weil sie sicher
ist die brennstoffe unerschöpflich sind
und die reaktion kein kohlendioxid oder
langlebigen radioaktiven abfall
produziert außerdem würde eine fusion
anlage nicht viel platz beanspruchen die
talker markt für sie unsere aktion
funktioniert etwas anders als wir es
beispielsweise vom stellarator aus
greifswald kennen denn hier wird das
magnetfeld zum teil von einem im plasma
fließenden strom erzeugt das konzept
beim töpfermarkt basiert also auf dem
magnetischen einschluss ein plasma aus
wasserstoff isotopen wird so auf etwa
100 bis 150 millionen grad erhitzt laut
der offiziellen website von poker mack
energy besteht die erste phase des
prozesses darin cluster temperaturen von
15 millionen grad celsius zu erreichen
also so heiß wie das zentrum der sonne
noch in diesem jahr will talker mark
energie dann 100 millionen grad
erreichen dann erst dann würden die
geladenen deuterium und tritium partikel
die sich normalerweise abstoßen
verschmelzen
das ziel des unternehmens ist es im jahr
2025 mit dem sc 40 erste elektrizität
herzustellen ein wahnsinniger
fortschritt und bis 2030 soll dann auch
kommerziell nutzbaren fusionsenergie
hergestellt werden das wäre der absolute
hammer und viel schneller als bei
anderen fusionsreaktoren bzw
experimenten das konzept des tokamak
reaktors ist nicht neu es wurde schon
1952 von zwei britischen musikern in
moskau entwickelt nur kurze zeit später
wurden dann auch die ersten tokamak
experimente durchgeführt der der begriff
zocker mag heißt übrigens übersetzt so
viel wie toro ideale kammer in
magnetspulen wobei die silbe talk auf
strom hindeutet und somit die
besonderheit des zuckermarkt prinzips
hervorhebt den stromfluss im plassmann
im frühling 2017 wurde talker mag in
betrieb genommen und das erste plasma
konnte erzeugt werden dazu hieß es in
der pressemitteilung
heute ist ein wichtiger tag für die
entwicklung von fusions energien
großbritannien und der welt wie es sie
40 ist eine maschine die fusions
temperaturen 100 millionen grad in
kompakten kostengünstigen reaktoren
zeigt damit kann
uns kraft in jahren nicht in jahrzehnten
erreicht werden das wäre wirklich eine
absolute revolution wenn er als erstes
neues zum thema kernfusion und zu allen
anderen themen erfahren wollen denn
endet hier meine telefonnummer prozent
dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen
anderen vom neuesten video täglich
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über
mich in der redaktion vom klick zum
mitmachen mir zum beispiel themen
vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen
teilnehmen und und in der begrüßungs
nachricht unbedingt sorgfältig lesen da
gibt es ein kleines goodie da haben sich
schon viele darüber gefreut also einfach
hier klicken und natürlich nicht das abo
mit der genau mit der glocke vergessen
hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken kernfusion vor dem
durchbruch
ansonsten bislang bleibt dran